You got to be careful with this drill.
So I g I give you caveats and just like
the coach the coach is setting you up,
do it like this so we get the result we
want. Okay. So when I shook my arms,
what did I say not to do?
>> Not to make too big a deviation.
The reason why is push. And you can see
how you can get your power into it,
right? Keep pushing. You're going to get
tired. Keep pushing. But once I go like
here, she can't ever get her power into
it. Do you understand? So I don't I'm
not trying to take force off of her. Uh
so does that make sense? So when I'm
shaking, she's she's driving. You could
use two hands. Okay. Um you could stand
up.
Yeah. I I'm not trying to do an Iikido
delevering of her. Do Do you understand?
So I'm I am feeling her. So I'm not
going to go and then she can't ever get
her legs into it. Okay? So I'm I have to
stay where I feel the urge to flex. Do
do you? Otherwise, I can't work on the
problem. Okay? All right. So try it
again.